fair warning there are times when you
think that you've programmed this
but you've actually commanded this
oh yeah so stick around we're going to
show you some special cases
where your programmed feed rate may not
be giving you what you expected
so we've got solutions for you in this
haas tip of the day
everything for me begins with my setup
sheet so check this out
i've got a block loaded up now if you're
tightening up those tools by hand
ah geometry we all love geometry
okay okay i love geometry so what we've
got here
are two circles one big and one
small now they've got different size
diameters right
they've got different size diameters big
diameter small diameter
and they also have different
circumference
the distance around those circles
what you will eventually find out is
that when you program a circular pocket
with a tool that is nearly the same size
as a hole itself
your effective feed rate might be 10
times higher
than what we had thought you might end
up with this
instead of this
now this happens because our tool thinks
that it's going this far
when it's actually going this far if you
see this and you will eventually
it's because our program feed rates are
based off the path
the center line of the tool follows and
not
the the path that the edge of the tool
follows which is much larger
here is the hole that we want to mill at
thousandths of an inch in diameter about
14 millimeters that's this outside black
line
we're gonna mill this circular pocket
with a tool that is
one half inch in diameter 0.5 inches
12.7 millimeters
550 minus 500 gives us
50.05 inches
now that's going to be the circle at the
center of our tool
that is created as this tool moves
around to create the pocket
that's where our feed rate is programmed
from
at the center of our end mill our tool
is programmed at
30 inches per minute f 30 but that's at
the center of our tool
out here at the edge of our tool where
we're at the 550 diameter things are
moving much
faster 11 times faster because
550 divided by 50 equals 11
11 times this outer circle is 11 times
bigger than the inside circle that our
feed rates are based on and we haven't
adjusted for that
here we'll show you this in a different
way i've loaded up an 11 inch
bar of steel and we're going to show you
what machine just that first
one inch would look like at a reasonable
feed rate
okay so that was normal let's cut
11 inches of steel in that same amount
of time
and see what that looks like
not good we're going to need to
compensate for this and we've got a few
solutions
solution number one which is always my
first choice
is to see if your cam system can
compensate for this
automatically now some cam systems like
mastercam
can override arc feed rates adjusting
the feed rate on every inside corner
if you'd like them to changing the feed
rate on every g2
or g3 arc move within a set range
now this is a nice feature but if your
cam system can't compensate for this
it's not the end of the world in my
experience this is only a big
deal when when milling circular pockets
with big end mills or when a thread
milling
and now that we know what to look for we
can compensate for this
manually ready for the formula machinist
love formulas
so here we go feed rate
times whole diameter minus
our tool diameter all divided by our
hole diameter
and we know from our example earlier
that we want our feed rate
our effective feed rate to be 30 inches
a minute so f 30
times our hole diameter 550
minus our tool diameter 500 all divided
by our hole diameter again 550.
now if we do the maths and we fill in
all the blanks we're going to end up
with a feed rate to be used in our
program of f
2.73 inches now with that f 2.73
at the center line of our tool we're
going to end up with an effective feed
rate of
30 inches a minute where it matters at
the edge
of our tool so if our if our
hole diameter is 11 times bigger than
our tool path diameter
then we need our feed rate to be 11
times smaller
we'll see this type of feed rate error
all the time when thread milling
when posting our programs from a cam
system our thread mill
is moving much faster at the edge of the
tool than it is at the center of the
tool
now we can use the same formula to
adjust our feed rate
for thread milling we just replace our
hole diameter with
our major thread diameter
so can the control do any of this
compensation for us
well it can but it's got to know what
your tool diameter
is so typically usually if you're
programming by hand
you'll just hand program to the part
contour
and then you'll enter in the tool
diameter on the tool offset page
under diameter geometry
and then when you call up cutter
compensation the control has everything
it needs to slow down
feed rates in tight corners this works
together with setting 44 it gets really
complicated
but just know that if you're using
cutter compensation and entering your
tool diameter
it is slowing your tool down for you in
those small radiuses
but most of us use a cam system to
program our parts
and when we program a cam system we let
it do all the heavy lifting
and then all we enter on our on our
offset page is
our diameter where our wear geometry
usually a small
number and we let the the cam system
adjust all of our feed rates the other
option is to compensate them
by hand like we showed you earlier with
those formulas
well that is all we've got for you this
time thanks for letting us be a part of
your success
and for watching this haas tip of the
day
[Music]
you